Okay, so we just looked at using a scalar value in our query
document for an array value field. Let's look at another way we can
query arrays in MongoDB. In this case we're going to introduce the IN
operator. Let's take a look at an example, and then we'll talk about it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so what happened there? IN allows us to specify an
array of values. In this query then, we'll retrieve all documents
for which the model years field contains any of the values
in this array here. We can use IN even if the
field we're querying against is not an array valued field. Thus
giving us a number of optional values that will match documents
in our result set. So we can see as I add
additional values to this array of options, that our count gets
larger and larger. Because we have a larger
and larger target that we can hit. K,
so let's take a look at the actual documents that are retrieved her. K, and if
we scroll up, we can see that in fact this document matches, as do the rest.
All of them containing at least one of
the values in their model year that we specified.